RANDY: I'm still
not fully awake.
There was this male
red deer last night
doing his thing, his bugles.
I can just imagine
when he's, like--
I was laying there in
bed, thinking, you know,
he's just calling out--
hey, girl.
Why don't you just
come on right over?
We could hang out, you know,
do our thing, just crawl--
crawl on over into my bed.
It's kind of what I imagined
he was saying, specifically
in that voice, too.
Let's see what's
the plan for today.
Might try to just fish all day.
Definitely starting to
feel the lack of energy
due to calorie deficiencies.
It's like I'm living
on minimum wage here,
and I'm kind of living day to
day as much as I possibly can.
So mainly, the thing
that I'm focused on
is finding a long
term food source--
that being a deer or
a lot of smoked fish.
RANDY (VOICEOVER): My survival
strategy isn't necessarily
about energy conservation.
Fish on.
RANDY (VOICEOVER): It's about
finding ways to live out here.
Ah, [bleep].
[bleep]
RANDY (VOICEOVER): There's a
correlation between how I'm
feeling mentally and emotionally
and the amount of food
that I'm getting.
Not having food is making things
a little bit more difficult
on me.
[bleep].
RANDY (VOICEOVER): I
can't get discouraged.
I want to make sure that
I put as much energy
into every aspect
of my life out here.
I feel like I can be successful
if I'm really persistent.
If you haven't been to a
spot in a while, they just,
uh, they forget.
I'm not sure what it is.
RANDY (VOICEOVER): It's just
a nice little boost at a time
when you need it.
Every little bit counts.
I've been out here a long time.
And I still can't believe
that I'm actually out here
and I'm doing it.
I'm successful.
And I will be the first one
to tell you that there are
times when I have my doubts.
All the fish on camera here.
All right.
Well, I'm calling it at nine.
Nine's a good number.
That gives me five--
after dinner and breakfast, that
gives me five fish to smoke--
10 halves, which is pretty good.
It's damn good.